hundreds of rescuers have fanned out in
search of those missing
diggers and earth movers continuously
shifting mounds
of debris and slush the rishi gangapa
project
they were working at is almost entirely
buried
there is palpable anger amongst the
relatives of those who are trapped
they want answers but the authorities
have none
you haven't found one body yet where are
the bodies
what some scientists are describing as a
glacial burst
has wrecked havoc down below and left
its mark
for miles white mud lines several feet
high show where debris
and water float down the valley
questions are now being raised by
environmentalists regarding power
projects and other big infrastructure
constructions
in this ecologically sensitive area of
uttarakhand
these himalayan mountains have been
warming at an alarming rate
rapid large and unchecked construction
has precipitated this even further
affecting the fragile ecosystem
this is the high risk areas and the
climate change hot spots region
so any development that you are doing
especially the uh one which
actually disturbs the local ecology
micro hydro is much better way
to develop or provide electricity than
the hydro
electricity program the large scale one
of the middle school one that we have at
this moment
74 year old bahadur tapriyal lives in
the villages on the mountain side
foreign
the events of sunday is a warning the
government
may or may not heat
but it's the vulnerable people of the
mountains that will bear the brunt
neville lazarus sky news in torpawan
uttarakhand